hello freak [ __ ] you see this [ __ ]
lady about WikiLeaks saying that this
that the CIA has access to all of our
phones fault seven yeah the leaks today
yeah what I didn't look through it yet
pull up a level because Edward Snowden
was saying that it's not whether or not
they can access you know whether they
have access to your encrypted [ __ ] it's
like that they've hacked Android and iOS
let's get into Android and iOS so if
you're some but here's the thing they're
saying they use it for espionage right
right so like if the Russians are here
you want to find out what they're up to
you can hack into their phone you get
their data well they're doing it too
it's like if some of our another we stop
the CIA from doing it right here's the
question if would you want if Russia is
doing it and China's doing in North
Korea and then all of a sudden the CIA
can't do it anymore aren't they at a
disadvantage yeah yeah that seems that
seems like we don't know what the [ __ ]
we're doing PSA this incorrectly implies
the CIA hacked those apps these apps
forward slash encryption but the doc
show iOS forward slash Android or what
got hacked a much bigger problem so
still working through the publication's
but what WikiLeaks has here is a
genuinely is genuinely a big deal looks
authentic see but I just I feel like we
we have to be very careful if other
people are doing things right so like if
you talk to people in the intelligence
community and I don't talk to a lot of
them but I have talked to a few what
they will tell you is you have to
understand that what the majority of the
American public thinks is going on in
the world and what their motives are and
what kind of espionage and [ __ ] dirty
tricks take place and it's way worse
than you think it is yeah you're way
lucky that you're sheltered from all
this stuff and they're just there's some
bad [ __ ] things that are going on in
the world yeah and one of those things
is I mean what you're looking at in
Russia right now is like an emerging
superpower run by a dictator yeah and
anybody who opposes him winds up dead
yeah have you seen all those [ __ ]
Russians that have wound up dead
recently they attach to these leaks this
wasn't there like what's the latest
count
yesterday and I love it I think there
was a Chevy one yesterday that died has
taken people out people just
mysteriously getting whacked and they're
billionaires oh really yes they're
whacking billionaires Jesus they're just
whacking people you know too much oh
yeah come fish let's go fishing
these guys are disappearing they're not
[ __ ] around Tom papa do you think
that control do you think that they did
they look at that Russian tip and I'll
keep dying unexpectedly look at his face
holy [ __ ] he's terrifying to me is
terrifying he's like one of those hell
pigs see we want to thank that the world
the world has learned from Hitler and
Stalin and Mussolini the world's learned
they're not going to do that again I
don't buy that no we don't know what
they say the number one says on here six
have died since November this is so does
Italy six doesn't I make you more
frightened that they were interfering in
our election well they certainly were
aware of what was going on and they
certainly had access to some documents
about the DNC the what what concerns me
is people that are ignoring although
that is an issue for sure right but
they're ignoring that what they did was
they let us know about some horrible
[ __ ] that the Democrats were up to where
they were rigging the primaries and
[ __ ] over Bernie Sanders because he
was too powerful and too dangerous to
Hillary Clinton
so they colluded they all used they
conspired rather and they all use their
influence to [ __ ] over Bernie Sanders
and then saying that the russians hacked
the election because they exposed that
the democrats are a bunch of cheat and
creeps is kind of disingenuous because
yes they did hack the election because
they did release some of that
information so they did have an impact
on it but that impact was essentially
the truth and something that we really
deserve to know in the first place we
deserve to know the inner workings of
the DNC we deserve know that that they
are getting in the way of democracy
they're rigging it yeah well there you
know yeah they're rigging it politics is
always dirty there's always the not
politics it's illegal what they were
doing was wrong like what they were
doing was they were they were
interfering with the democratic process
whether or not it's illegal to be argued
in court and maybe should be right but
it's most sir
not what anybody wants not want the DNC
to dictate who the we honor winner of
the primary is now we all people the
dictator we also didn't want Joe Kennedy
putting people didn't want Joe Kennedy
putting his bribing and stealing votes
for his son to be alleged of his always
go on but but doesn't excuse it but the
we now are you siding up to that guy
mmm you know what I mean right that that
guy for whatever reason it is he wants
to defeat us right so any kind of any
kind of influence and the people within
that campaign are now having to they're
getting caught talking to them and then
they lied about it for some reason they
didn't want people to know whatever that
was about and now you have this foreign
enemy who is now sidled up with a lot of
the people who are now running our
government right a government by the way
that isn't that is hell-bent on tearing
a lot of stuff down you're right but
what they the only reason why it worked
at all was because the Democrats were
involved in shady [ __ ] it's not like
they made up some stuff right Shiva not
dude I'm saying yes she's dirty they
were dirty yeah he was dirty but okay
I'll give you the results not good
results not good no no having Donald
Trump win in this fashion and having the
Russians interfere and then also having
some sort of an influence on him
financially right all those things are
not good yeah but it's a little
disingenuous to destroy the fact that
Hillary was a terrible candidate yes she
was so compromised from so many
different angles I mean she didn't
support gay marriage until 2013 I think
it was yeah she didn't she not only that
she I mean like the Clinton Foundation
is just a disaster like the whole thing
ends up and even filled with Annie Jerry
Shea yeah and look she was definitely
disliked by a lot of people from being
there for a lot of time doing stuff that
made a lot of people very nauseous well
she might get all that not honest but I
don't want to I don't want to go back
and redo the election but breast it just
does it concern you that if let's say
let's be conspiracies on the other
concerns lately that the Russians that
the Russians have so much more influence
over this president mm-hmm he's by the
way putting his American first is using
Russian steel for that pipeline that's
going through the Indians if he's that
tied to them and they're and russia's an
enemy of ours they want us to fail and
now they have an administration that
wants to tear stuff down it could that
be a conspiracy theory on that side it
certainly could but here's the problem
what you're saying they like the russian
they want to do this they want to do
that right we're buying their steel they
don't operate as an individual you know
a bunch of people that are trapped in
this dictatorship with this russian
oligarch yeah well the Putin but it's
when you are buying things if you're
buying things from Russians these are
their individuals over there is
everything Russia and entity and their
entity wants us dead right once is
doomed isn't it pilot about the people
well isn't it possible that their
government their government can evolve
like an they can essentially not have
that guy in place so there's some
something could take place yes and they
could also prosper from this age of
information and a hundred percent right
people to people one hundred percent
yeah I mean this guy is doing this thing
I don't know what he's doing our guy I
don't know if this conspiracy like to
just to just to take the fantasy Oh are
these guys right because like you're
saying the WikiLeaks explodes out of the
DNC there's also a lot of dirty stuff we
don't even know right now that's going
on for sure on both sides let's just
take this fantasy of okay so Putin is
really aggressively wanted this
administration and they wanted a Bandhan
who wants to tear stuff down this is an
advantage for us right if you can expose
that I think that's a that's a big deal
yes it also era but here's a problem
you're making a bunch of stuff up in
order because yeah you know I said a
fantasy yeah but that's I I get what
you're saying but I mean I'm not saying
shouldn't be able to do it of course you
could and it's something that should be
considered but it's a weird thing when
you start making up motives and
potential outcomes and look it's not
good not having this guy's why they're
investigating do they try and find the
answers of what
stuff really is what is all sorts of
[ __ ] that's not good there's all sorts
of [ __ ] that's not good about this whole
situation yeah there's like there's way
too much power and influence by one
person and that person's that person's
cabinet and that person's choices like
what what choice they make on the rest
of us and we're seeing that now way it's
way too much way too much and it's more
than we've ever seen before we've never
seen someone come in with this sweeping
brush of change yeah and just decide no
[ __ ] Abama care no building that [ __ ]
wall no you run those pipes nope Dakota
Pipeline [ __ ] you we're coming through
like whoa it's it's happening within the
first thirty game doesn't it seem a lot
of it's mean me let's take you know
Dakota vote on both sides Dakota
pipeline seems mean she dumping waste
into the water seems mean what is that
waste and water where they dump them
coal waste where as I made it illegal in
West Virginia so that you couldn't know
it again and I can dump it again like
there's like I want that talk about
shutting down scaring PBS well those
guys sucked over now not my brother for
a donation this is all mean [ __ ] like
why can't have different people making a
cooking shows that attacking time right
is that what it is no they it's always a
Republican thing I think it's just to
get people mad but you know what I mean
like just can't you act out of kindness
if you enjoyed any part of this program
and you'd like to donate please do we
survive on donations
we appreciate you I always think that
those guys just can't wait to Nazz that
[ __ ] shows on the run home and put a
ball gag on punch themselves in the dick
just they're so tied down that's so not
how a man thinks are talking so buddy
for tuning in yes yes very interesting
fresh air with Terry Gross is up next
very interesting we're going to talk
about who are you who are you [ __ ] what
would you do if a terrorist attack was
happening right now what would you do if
a man came in with a dick in his hand
want to [ __ ] your mouth well how would
you react well I mean there's probably a
reason he wants to do that Wow
we have to understand that I'm not
consenting you're presenting to you
doing this to me there's probably a very
good reason his father probably did it
to him and I just don't uh you know what
I mean I just it feels like like Kaitlyn
and we come from a place of jobs of
kindness rather than well he's about
prosperity right now he's ramping up the
prosperity that's what he wants to do
yeah I think he feels like he can get
people to love him again and get the
country on track if he creates all these
jobs that's we had this big video
announcing great where where he was
talking about Exxon investing in the
Gulf Coast and they're going to get all
these jobs and there's going to be like
45,000 jobs the job is going to be
paying $100,000 on the average so all
these great jobs and he's very excited
about announcing that most likely not
idle well it's all types of oil that's
where the money is and resources right
in that bottom in that old model and you
don't know it doesn't have to be that
model but he wants to get America dead
echoing there are hundreds of people to
work thousands their houses are skinned
people they're [ __ ] driving cars
they're killing people I love our
peoples life brought up two people died
too we're acting like hot by the way
yeah who were like whoa I'm looking at
videos on his iPad dude autonomous cars
are coming whether you like it or not
it's the best do you do it with yours
yeah you turn your chest on just start
beating off yes
I'm hard right now that you just said
Tesla do you do it everywhere just on
the highway or honey not on the on the
freeway and you put your hands on the
wheel at all sometimes a little bit
y'all keep them loose on it but
sometimes if it's traffic I don't touch
it at all and I'm stirring email you're
returning emails where you're driving
I'm not driving the cars driving that's
so nuts man yeah if you're in traffic
just going to coupes you know and so we
the car takes over you take the exit
that it's supposed to take now you're
out you got to do that you take over
when you leave it oh it's the next
living version that comes out the end of
this year is good what do you invite
when you leave it the freeway oh so it
only works on a freeway no it works on
side streets but it doesn't read stop
signs or
or what traffic legs what kind of piece
of [ __ ] is this it's a if it's got its
hasn't got the update it needs the GPS
and all this other stuff to to work to
do surface streets but when it's on the
freeway the car is reading the cars in
front of it around it but doesn't have
GPS and the and the signs these signs
were how about here crossing deer
crossing he's a deaf child I know Becca
Chin's are under something as family
that's the most depressing [ __ ] thing
everyone driver from San Diego aware of
immigrant crossings a mother holding a
child's hand the father holding the
mothers hand like oh man I was not those
[ __ ] people come over this is the
worst I was just in Mexico doing a gig
and they kept asking people about about
Trump they would be able late ask us
about Trump or you know Soho Mexican
bank and a couple of them especially the
last guy was like yeah Dino everybody I
don't know he seems bad but have you met
our president all their presidents
Terrell he's the most corrupt guy he
doesn't help any of us he's awful it was
like oh right yeah he's way were you
your leaders a [ __ ] - you know all
the killers all of them yeah and these
are like the leaders that are probably
the best yeah because you go like how
about that guy in the Philippines is
just shooting people yeah you're out
there doing drugs I'm shooting you
you
[Applause]
[Music]